[Music]
in bad memes news Oh is there such a
thing yesterday
submitted by to top to top I was like a
rapper together academics are warning
lawmakers that means may contribute to
teenage obesity what wow how do they
make that connection just laughing their
fat ass off alright I don't get it
what's contributes memes all memes are
making people fat I mean if their food
memes oh yeah so these academics are
advising to British lawmakers that memes
are contributing to teenage obesity so
here are some of the examples that they
use how does that contribute don't you
not want to be that help me hmm no
because it's encouraging to be the best
not just memes than this everywhere dude
there's advertisements like what are
they [ __ ] here's another one like you
know it's just like encouraging
unhealthy life oh like saying it's okay
it's normal okay we're all part of this
group together that's the same [ __ ] as
when things would be like violence is
like rap music encourages style yeah you
know what does make people fat though
[ __ ] month-long videos that [ __ ] if I
see someone eating I'm like I want that
right now
what's that is it Carl's jr. or whatever
but their marketing is just kind of like
bucket we gonna be fat was it like dog
in butter
maybe it's Wienerschnitzel but it was
kind of just like that would be amazing
if that was a direct market but they
were just like yeah like grubbing you
know slogan uh no it's like they're
super unapologetic about it they're just
like [ __ ] yeah just be like what was one
of the commercials that did that that's
why I don't remember but I don't know I
was hoping you guys would remember but I
just talked about like those skinny
girls that are in those huge burger no
no it was like straight up in your face
like we don't count calories our life we
don't do that I remember one old school
when it was if it doesn't get all over
the place that's belong in her face I
like that one is that like sauces and
[ __ ] all porno that was fire a lot of
come jokes came with that though so much
sexual you know Jordan wasn't one of
those of this I think that the cats have
dropped on his Jordans oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're just saying here that
commercials internet memes are generally
viewed as entertaining that they also
represent a body of culture practice
that does not account for the specific
needs and rights of teenagers unhealthy
lifestyle that's not fair
cuz what about all the fitness ones are
all the motivational ones well no they
do mentor there are positive ones
but like there's focusing on the
negative ones here well I mean this is
also a counter toward the super diet
like I've always got to be skinny this
one's more like [ __ ] dude I don't have
to look like you I'm gonna eat whatever
I want
I wondered because I feel like people
are more healthy now than they were like
40 or 50 years ago just because there's
a lot more knowledge and people are
being more self conscious with it I mean
there still are people who have that you
know the chubb movement or whatever the
fad movement or whatever but that's like
I think that's very small
I think it's ball with I mean there's
more sedentary people too and more
active people so there's no middle it's
just like this seems well there was no
BCD problem back 50-plus years ago but
what I was watching this [ __ ] of like
how it got here it's because of the
Great Depression and everybody's
starving so they're like all right man
we got to feed everyone to make sure
that no one goes starving so that was
the campaign with like the farming
industry the government everybody is
just packing super high calorie dense
foods and then you know we got use of
that kind of eating and then now no one
goes hungry but now everyone's dying
from eating too much yeah it's kind of
like the the public school system they
do high calorie dense like lunches for
the kids cuz there's a lot of like poor
kids that the only meal that they get is
from their lunch so it's gotta be like
2,000 calorie [ __ ] up
crazy junk food stuff yeah Cheetos and
nacho cheese oh no breakfast burrito I
miss school food sometimes yeah she was
fired my ass too I never understood
people talk [ __ ] about school food I
always loved that shitty too we're poor
that's one because that was like our
dough past food you sure it was a dope
food home I'll just get kimchi and write
you know but that was the white people
food I don't get to eat yeah I got
chocolate milk and a cherry juice oh
that's a cherry juice you know I would
come like the milk was like this big and
in the juice box is like this big but
what's cherry cherry I got change you so
I got grape juice I'm a chalupa oh yeah
the little you get the let me put the
lettuce and the hot sauce wasn't that
you know it's a get the taco sauce make
a little zigzag all the food that I ate
in high school was made to destroy my
intestinal lining breakfast tacos used
to make you fart like all day the the
South tortilla with the the meat sloppy
joe day was this [ __ ] it was really
quiet it sounded like you were just like
because it was quiet you were like I'll
be the home girl and like vac you up
that's what it sounded like
yeah have you guys ever had Arby's yeah
Barbies I've had it like one time I've
had it recently but I love Arby's dude
but I just felt like [ __ ] afterwards
like meaning like I just felt like I
just ate a whole bunch we're
contributing to [ __ ] obesity right
now guys this is what the problem
knowledge is getting bobbi's is shitty
ooh but the bread is so good it's so
soft what's your favorite Taco Bell okay
baby all day about voted the healthiest
fast what yeah do you hear that gel I
don't care about hell I'm talking about
fast food in a now it's not even part of
this conversation right not some
restaurants ago or else I would have
said boo but we just gonna love it and I
just had it to that show fire those are
like one of those fast food joints okay
if it disappears I'll be really isn't it
Oh fast food if the food is already
ready and then you could get it or or
it's frozen it's not if you're if you're
reheating as fast food but if it's
starting from scratch is not fast food
really cuz I consider whatever I can
walk up and my pay you right away and
then it's quickly then that's always
trips considered fast food to you uh to
me yeah
so what's fast casual and cuz there's
fast casual there's fast food there's
there's a different in my world it's
just fast food or restaurant I just want
to take certain pieces from certain fast
food places that's where the issue comes
right cuz I'm not gonna get a chalupa
for McDonald's so I want the chalupa
from here I want the filet-o-fish for
McDonald's and the chicken nugget like a
food court
my mom Bart does that from time to time
he goes we go to like four or five
different oh [ __ ] that's really smart
dude it's this Taco Bell KFC McDonald's
do you eat it there first or do you have
to collect it he collects it oh but it
gets cold he doesn't care and there's
also time to just post mates for my four
places
[Music]
well they allow you to have multiple
yeah you can constantly you could put
like you can't have a whole [ __ ]
queue of ordered if you watch I do to
places like after day of drink like the
next day when I'm hungover my post mates
order doesn't make any sense like much
it like a pregnant yeah it's all over to
play I got like chili cheese fries from
the Hat and then I got fried chicken
from Popeyes and then I got a cookies
and cream milkshake from fat burger how
can you eat fried stuff like taking it
home fried stuff has to be like the
first 30 seconds unless it's Tokyo this
is pretty good just brought it yeah it
was still really good Oh
have you had that no what is that okay
fried chicken no it's like a Japanese
southern cajun fusion place is really
good their sides are really good too
macaroni and cheese is amazing so other
colors that's around your awai
it's really good it's really good they
got a yuzu lemonade why don't they teach
kids me why don't they teach kids
self-discipline instead of like blaming
memes and [ __ ] yes well they always try
to push it like parenting on other
people it's like what the [ __ ] like why
would you blame others weren't raising
your [ __ ] kids it's hard to have
discipline if you're like a 10 year old
you know ya don't so much he doesn't
funny yes but then that should have the
balance should happen at home right cuz
that's what you can control yeah but
what about if you make PE like 2 hours
long a hardest [ __ ] it is hard man that
[ __ ] quarter-mile job was [ __ ] kid
she was boring but I'm say let's say you
make P hard as [ __ ] like everyone is
like you gotta climb a rope that goes
straight you're leading parenting on
other people so don't put in physical
education you like academic people that
so they're saying make it like a Spartan
Race yeah a Spartan Race everyday yeah
that might actually be fun kids max you
like it I wasn't working we used to do
this thing called the all school run it
was like a mile and a half what I would
do is I would still have my backpack on
from when I came to school and I would
do it all school run out the parking lot
and back home
yeah all the [ __ ] time you're like
mr. so where are you guys Lee you know
where the [ __ ] I'm going man like you
don't know no no yeah so these academics
here they're saying that unhealthy
lifestyle cost the NHS billions of
dollars every year which so remember
we're talking about UK here so that's
the reason why they're telling British
lawmakers that internet memes are
contributing to their obesity crisis in
the UK know what's really doing it is to
parents overworked so then because
traditionally a lot of women are gonna
hate this but housewives were the ones
to cook and do that stuff right so there
was a lot of attention and care being
able to like cook fresh home-cooked
meals for the family but then now that
both parents are like working all day
long it's hard because in some families
the women still have to do that plus
work right so what ends up happening is
like they're gonna buy the products that
are easy made easy
like you could microwave this [ __ ] in
five minutes boom because like after
eight I mean eight hour shift you don't
wanna like slave in the kitchen that's
[ __ ] hard so that you know plus the
the preservatives and all the [ __ ] up
like processed foods and then like you
know what's gonna sell better better
tasting foods that's the big problem not
[ __ ] memes I'm gonna have the biggest
trouble like when I have a kid because I
know what's healthy for them but I
trying to eat that [ __ ] it's like hey
you'll be surprised you'll change
because you know that you're the direct
influence to your child see about that
I've seen a lot of hypocritical
parenting from everybody including my
parents too
[Music]